hello my name is Jose Martin Garcia and
I will be talking about what's new in
version 12 of the world from language in
the Geo functionality
so I'm going to talk about what's new in
geography there are many things to talk
so let's start so the the main functions
like geography your image elevation data
have been largely rewritten internally
so that the things that are being
presented today were implemented and new
things that will come next can be
implemented so the underlying or the the
overall idea was that until now
Geographics has been controlled mostly
by properties of ranges on the earth
like ranges of latitudes and longitudes
etc so that was very intuitive very
simple to use
however the maps that you got in output
sometimes were not exactly what you
wanted because if you just started with
a square range of latitude and longitude
that didn't mean that the final map will
be a square right so there is an
alternative way of controlling the maps
which is controlling the details of the
final projected ranges and final
projected positions and so what you will
see here is how the new functions have
been extended and improved to follow
that idea so the first one that we are
going to see is the image so for example
the image was introduced in verse 1 xi 2
and if you ask for a new image of a map
of Turkey say it is a bit bigger so you
get that map right so now we have the
new option aspect ratio which is one of
the many new options that your image
gained and as you can just say give me a
square map and this map will be exactly
square and this is this will happen in
any projection it doesn't matter which
relation you will use the map will be a
square you can control also the maps
simply by saying I want in the projected
space again this size so this many
pixels so if you asked for the image the
dimensions of that image you get exactly
what you wanted and we can
also even control independently the
image size so how do you see it in
screen and you see it's the same size of
before as you forth and the actual
roster size that the image has
internally so if you ask now for image
dimensions you get 300 300 okay so as I
was saying something very important is
to control maps by projected ranges so
let me show here this is the UTM grid so
this is a projection Universal
transverse Mercator projection that
divides the earth on these six the bands
sisty stripes and each of them is very
good very little distortion on the area
it covers after the the poles right so
you can imagine like having these
stripes that cover the Earth from pole
to pole and you have 60 of them they are
completely disjoint on the equator but
if you see here is valve art for example
it appears multiple times
right because near the poles they
overlap with each other so for example
we selected the point for Chicago so
Chicago appears only in this one which
is band number 16 that tooltip is 16 so
we know that if we want to work around
Chicago it's good to use the UTM zone 16
so that's the coordinates of Chicago in
the UTM zone 16 and this is expressed in
meters because distortion is very low in
this in this bands we can actually use
meters and so for example now we can say
give me a map of Chicago with a you see
now we don't say dia range we see geo
grid range we are explicitly asking for
their projected ranges and we as we say
this is the number of meters from the
left side of the band and this is the
number of meters from the equator right
so that because these two ranges are the
same in in size we get a square map and
we have the ticks here express in meter
so this is exactly or very approximately
20 kilometers and 20 kilometers and you
can do the same thing in the image right
so you can ask for you can specify the
UTM zone 16
and give me the map of this geogrid of
this geogrid wrench so this projection
is very used for example the military
grades are based on this projection the
military Greeks are based on this
projection and the third thing about
your image you know that in your image
we have access to very good resolution
satellite imagery and every this is
something that the ball from research
pays for and every user has a free quota
of digital globe tiles per month so
please use it we need to evaluate how
how useful this is and if you doesn't
use it one month it's lost so all the
counters are reset for the next month so
I invite you to use it so this is a for
example an image of the Adler
Planetarium here in Chicago and we have
this new option also to say I want a
resolution of three feet this is the
average distance pixel to pixel all
right so you don't have to worry about
some levels and things like that it
depends on the equator or the poles
right so in the crater which is the
worse situation we can get some 15 even
lower than a meter the lower meter we
run a feet and then as you go up in
latitudes it gets better but there's a
cosine factor okay next function the
elevation data the elevation data we've
had three options until now and it has
15 now so it's a much more powerful
function now though geoserver is still
is there but it's it can only connect to
our server at the moment so in the
future it will be extended as well so
for example what we were doing until now
is using always the job projection
equirectangular because that's what the
data is originally in so if you ask for
say Alaska and I'm choosing explicitly a
region which is quite north you get you
got something like this which is highly
distorted so now you can do us in
Geographics
you can say choose automatically
projection or you can choose any
projection you want and now you get a
much more faithful representation of the
area and for example you can use that
data which comes as a quantity array as
usual or in feet or meters depending on
where you are and now you can you see
see this 3d region of the representation
of the makeup of the area yeah right and
this is the the proper thing that you
would need to if you want to 3d printed
or something you have to have this
region this representation yes something
to stress here is that because the array
representation and the representation
needed by these functions is the
opposite you always need to use our
reverse here don't forget that because
the way you will get orientations wrong
sometimes when the map is very local you
don't you don't realize it for example
Stephen always forgets that and he
always get get at the ever this mountain
clips okay or you can use data reversed
either either of those yeah you can if
you are very interested in the actual
positions of each of those values of
elevation you ask for at your position
object and you get this more than half a
million point values all tagged with
their respective locations exactly
for example now we can do Antarctica
right because this can choose any
projection so so we can have an acting
Muto projection for Antarctica so so
this is quite nice as well or we can
choose we can add a scaling function I'm
sorry a color function and yeah so this
color function which is special for for
elevations it takes into account the
sine and yeah and so this is the region
around the North Pole and so you see
here
Greenland and that the Canada Alaska
Russia let's connect okay so yeah so
this is all new and of course we can use
all the new options you can we can
control this by grid ranges we can
control also the actual size of the
array we want back so they say 500 by
500 that's what you get we can use
exactly like Geographics use the chooser
center just a range a lot of flexibility
on how to choose the elevation okay
something we have added as well is
random field position so now we can
evaluate random job position by default
it will give you a ideal position
anywhere on the earth and the first
argument can be either specification of
number or dimensions if you want an
array or the region we can say give me a
point around on to your position in the
United States or give me 100 or 500 gear
position randomly and by default they
are uniformly distributed on area in
area right so we get that time or for
example remember that if you want to
include Alaska Hawaii you have to use a
year variant that says give me a
principle area if you want to include
other things like 1 etc you would have
to use all areas but now we can also get
the points distributed and included
including there is a point here so again
the projection is fundamental here
because when we ask for say a thousand
random positions of the world those for
example appear uniformly distributed in
equal area projections like this for the
first four are equal area projections
and you see they are exactly the same
points and they don't look uniform in
all projections however if you go to
other types of projections like this is
a correct angular or Mercator you see
they don't look uniform at all right
because there's a lot of space in the
market
around the polls so if you want points
that look uniform in the Mercator
projection you have to specify it you
have to specify the projection in which
you want uniformity and now for example
we get back a thousand points again but
in the equal area projections they they
accumulate a lot around the point around
the poles and even in the correct angle
projections they don't look right but
America the projection they will look
correct so you can choose which
projection do you want to have
uniformity in another thing that we have
added is ways of extracting information
from your position and so it now has all
these properties so you can extract
latitude and longitude you can extract
latitude longitude or because sometimes
this is what is needed you can extract
longitude latitude you can get
information which is not explicitly
there but it's implicitly there so that
like the default datum we always use
even if you don't know you are using a
potato elevation by default when you
don't use a Geo position it's assumed to
be on the ellipsoid so elevation zero
with respect to the ellipsoid
and your positions actually store events
events in space-time so they also have a
date
you can specify as a fourth element of
the list you can specify an absolute
time in in DMT and so the date by
default is now if you know specify they
assume it to be now you can ask for a
number of points you have if they are
packed which which is the packing type
they are using and this is also down for
every type of the opposition like the
opposition XYZ so we can extract various
combinations of the values remember that
these are coordinates in meters with
respect to a frame Center at the centre
of the earth and oriented with respect
to range and under North Pole
and other objects also gain properties
like geo displacements right so if you
have a displacement of a thousand miles
in the north northeast direction so the
angle arguments in the Geographics
framework are able to understand these
notations or the by notation like north
east by north and things like that and
yeah that's you have various properties
here okay more things something
completely new geo vectors so this is a
new flavor of geodetic object and it's
it's a it's a bit like like a cow's into
geo position the most important thing to
realize from the very beginning is that
these are not geo primitives right do
you need to rub them around with
something to convert them into something
to come plot in a map same thing as with
your position if you put your position
in a map you know will not see a point
or a marker or anything you have to wrap
around it point or your marker whatever
same thing is going to happen with geo
vector so your vector has also four
flavors in parallel to the opposition
itself so you we have the vector your
vector e and you your vector X Y Z and
your grid vector and they follow the
same type of coordinate system that the
opposition itself is following so for
example the en you means is north up so
that's the frame that's tangent at a
given location or the X Y C so this is a
frame that is oriented with respect to
the XYZ frame of the earth itself so for
example what's an example here so we can
ask geomagnetic model data for the value
of the magnetic field vector field here
now because remember the magnetic field
is something quite alive and we get back
this so the structure of Geo vector is
always the same it says this is the
position and this is the value of the
vector the vector here in this case is a
vector in nano Tesla's but it can't have
any units can be our velocity it can be
an acceleration it can be a flow
migration whatever
so you can have any any coordinate any
units the en you form means this is the
east component the north component sorry
II yes the north component and up
component so in this case we see that
the the fundamental part of the magnetic
field here is vertical and pointing
downwards and Geo vector is another of
these flavors it acts as a container and
as a converter exactly like at your
position so we can convert this it will
keep the position exactly in the same
way but now we have the vector in a
different form so now it's some sort of
cylindrical form so we have this is the
norm of the horizontal part that's the
bearing remember angle with respect to
North clockwise in degrees and that's a
vertical part which is the same so we
see here for example that here the
magnetic field is not pointing exactly
north it's pointing a bit to the west
three degrees and so now we want to plot
it in a map so we use your marker so
your marker can take vectors and because
they are vectors it will draw arrows the
second argument is a vector marker
argument and it has the full freedom
that Brad was explaining yesterday for
vector plot so we can have here darts
and drops and all these for all these
things that the vector marker all right
and so you see this this vector is a bit
tilted to there to the left
now the the important thing from the
point of view Geographics is that if we
use any other projection of course the
vet the vectors are going to know what
are what is their proper direction and
so here you see how north is now
pointing in that direction and so the
vector is pointing in that direction so
this is all automatic all every rotation
change of norm excetera will be
controlled by Geographics itself via the
projection so the back
can be 2d or 3d and here I have a
manipulator in which we don't need to
look at the code but the thing here is
that we I want to compare the difference
between a vector which is here and I'm
choosing here I don't know miles per
hours you see it doesn't have to be a
distance with a Geo path that your path
is a true displacement on the earth it's
a distance based displacement right so
we have something like tooth yeah 2500
miles
however the vector can have the same
direction but the norm is completely in
a different frame right and so yeah so
here you see the difference so the
vector is pointing in the same direction
as the co path but of course the
interpretation is quite different and if
we go to market or so in the Mercator
projection we have similar situation all
in the lumber or a similar production in
which discs circles look properly
circular okay they were saying
Geographics will control all changes in
direction and etc so here we have this
frame the the vector pointing its east
the vector pointing north and then some
arbitrary vector that okay
so if I change this to say this position
and I do this do you see how the vector
is changing in in norm so because this
is a perspective well this is a
projection that we understand visually
we understand what's happening here
however if we go to say I don't know
lambert azimuthal and we try to play the
same game so here it's not intuitive at
all what should happen so when the
vector is going to become shorter or
when the vector is going to become
longer etc
and Geographics will control that for
you so everything related to the
projection you can have many many
vectors so we now have say random geo
position of a hundred points and 100
vectors right this will they will kind
of collect all the vectors at the same
location and so we see that they are
mostly all oriented towards north and
those represent the geomagnetic model
the German the magnetic vector field in
the area of Canada you see they are
pointing towards some place there which
is where were there the vector field
dips and it becomes more or less
vertical and yeah that also explains why
the vectors are getting shorter because
this is the horizontal projection right
so the vectors in this area almost
vertical and you can plot many vectors
you see the difference between using the
vector directly and using the vector
plot or the stream plot is that with
your vector we will plot their vectors
at their positions with your vector plot
some sort of smoothing will be done and
then you will get a kind of a complete
vector field you can control sizes
colors everything okay I have two more
minutes and the last thing we have added
is geo distortion and scales so the idea
here is well how much is that my
projection distort in things so to
understand this we have to understand
that in order to go from the earth to
the map there are three steps first we
choose a datum which is some sort of
very good approximation to the earth but
keeping the right size then we go from
the datum to our reference model this is
also called a generating glove in the
literature flow in the literature and
here we perform a certain factor this is
what in the maps they usually write like
1 : 100,000 so that's the nominal scale
right so that's that this step of going
from the data to the reference model and
finally from the reference model which
is still earnest Freud we go to a flat
map and in this step
don't change scales but it gets very
distorted so when we talk about scales
in a map we are combining two things the
global champion factor in the middle
scale and the distortion at the point
this is constant this is point
independent so these three new functions
control both things for the three
fundamental objects we are always
worried India which is distance area and
direction and when we go to Year 3d we
will add volume here so for example
what's what's the so we have this
function you agreed unit distance that
reports that in the Mercator projection
around Copenhagen in the direction of 45
degrees we have like 40 miles that means
that in this map if we go to the
Mercator projection from Copenhagen 40
miles that is basically the same
distance as a as a tick here right so
you can understand this number as one of
my tics the distance corresponding to a
tick in a map is 40 miles in reality
around that point and this will depend
from point to point
right so this is controlling the
distance distortion around that point so
we can do the same thing with area so
and this is quite useful for example
when you want to do operations on the
projected space imagine that you say I
have this map of Venus and and I have
this disk and I want to compute the true
area on the earth so what we have to do
is to integrate these on the projected
coordinates but taking into account the
conversion factor of area right so I
have this function which is computing
the numbers that we have here just
convert it into kilometers squared and
then we can integrate the area of this
disk and get kilometer square back but
you see this is a computation perform in
projected this is not a geodesic it's
true this in projected space but with
these we can do any type of operation
and this is like the area element the a
of the integration right it has the
distinct so it's more intuitive what is
going on and then
finally another function to control
distortion of angles it's basically
saying all these two vectors were
originally orthogonal but now they are
not by this different so it's telling
you how many degrees they go together or
more separate for conformal projection
like Mercator there is no distortion and
this is always zero okay so I conclude
here with slide about many things to do
in the future so we want to enter
elevation in all full details including
vertical datums we want to add many more
protocols of communications in geoserver
to to access a lot more information of
course we have the new great technology
for polygons with holes so we want to
use that do we want to start moving
Geographic stored vector data vector
mean means here opposed to raster data
starting with labels in projection land
we have to do oblique and interrupted
projections and then of course modular
data the Geo part of the spatial
statistics that the statistics group is
developing and Astronautics full new
projects linked to do thank you
[Applause]